today's guest is a small hero of sorts
he's the kind of boy man that uh that
sometimes you just imagine is just
scurrying through your garden and
stealing squashes are still in uh a
couple karotz you know it he is part of
the tiger belly podcast he he's the
tiger with the belly comedian actor
effervescent human mr. Bobby Lee
[Music]
that little pari squirrel himself boy
what's up Bukka you know what bro Papa
needs an apology I think he does yeah
because you start a war with Papa
right now on the streets people call me
do wrong oh yeah they do yeah everywhere
I go I want to say something about here
if they call you a delivery higher but
let me tell you something bro yeah
you've been the NAM bro huh I've been
you've been right yeah they've been
doing this haircut for years
you see platoon Papa they all did this
[ __ ] ho Chi Minh bro mm-hmm so what I'm
saying is that I didn't steal it from
you I stole it from the greats from wait
but here's the thing bro you coming into
you know the world we live in bro
there's only so many types of styles
everybody has a style right you know
everybody has a like Chris D'Elia has
that kind of like Rick Springfield kind
of concrete ballerina yeah you got your
boy slick red over there [ __ ]
oh that freak yeah yeah he's got red
heads can't do nothing that ganger bro
right they can do two things the one he
has in the know Ron Howard yeah he's got
that right you gotta go bald to do wrong
right right but my say something to you
my friend yes we've been waiting for
decades to hear whatever it is Bieber
right yeah you know the Bieber who
Justin Bieber no franklinb yeah you
don't know Frankie no Justin Bieber bro
JB yeah JB do remember his haircut they
always said that's the Bieber cut right
that bull crossover you know the
comb-over but the Chinese been doing
that for 2,000 years bro you can't just
call the Bieber out of nowhere so what
I'm saying is the mullet ain't feel
Vaughn it's just a mullet but here's the
thing brah it's not a mullet okay it is
a display of your heart it's a display
of your ambiance brah it's a display of
your freaking virility and your raw
ability yeah you know it's
[ __ ] bro it's that 3-inch baby cape
yeah bro you gotta let that thing dangle
brother right do you feel better with it
you must feel more empowered I feel much
more empowered I feel like I can bang
southern chicks better really yeah yeah
yeah yeah you can definitely run out of
gas
yeah yeah I just feel like I can go to a
trailer oh yeah right and just rip up
the holes you don't mean yeah whether it
be you know a pillow or a woman it
doesn't matter Oh some reverse driver
right yeah just tie anything you know
like that but my point is is that maybe
you're right maybe I get it because
you're so you're you know I admire you
it's hard to say what died Mario oh oh
yeah my admirer you're making it one
here I understand that but here's the
thing some people you come with a
certain style you get then people gonna
say you're a certain thing you know
cornrow your [ __ ] hair people gonna say
you're Tiffany Haddish yeah yeah yeah
you know you shave off all your body
hair we tell people gonna say you're
Joey wrote if you see a fat fro yeah
Eric Griffin yeah you're right Griffin
with little [ __ ] uh you probably
bedazzles it that's complaining a lot he
could bleed the love bra Oh brah I love
him dude that fat [ __ ] he is he still
fat I don't think so but that's not
really fat that it's just the
sickle-cell anemia in your body you know
I mean that's causing the way they used
to have an urban show sickle-cell
Saturday I remember and it was a where
urban comedy where Memphis oh really
sickle-cell Saturday yeah Wow in Memphis
man you do good in front of black people
I don't mom I mean black people don't do
blind people support that much that many
white things though do they support any
white entertainment yeah I mean I just
played her vine and I had one black
person our vines hard that guy comes to
my shows yes Steve yes Steve yeah Steve
Smith yeah he was adopted so Steve was
there at my shows at Irvine every show
oh yeah yeah but
ever I see groups of black African
America or what do you call it black I
say black friends are urban gentlemen
yeah my lamb within the eye or the first
48 that's right
but when they come I get really excited
you do yeah because it's like you know
I'm reaching you know I like to reach
everybody I know I do [ __ ] joke's on
you know on stage I don't think you do
man
thanks you've been doing a lot of new
stuff some you know because I have to do
a special I think eventually oh yeah
yeah so many fun like new haircut new
special yeah bro I want to UM but do you
think that but I feel like white people
support a ton of black entertainment
they do I don't feel like black that
does the same as the reverse way do you
feel that way well you know you have
different kinds of blacks right you have
the ones that are like terraria know
Nigeria order are chemically yeah yeah
yeah thinking black okay TB they could
beat you in chess at any moment right
right right but then you got the Aaron
Hernandez people that hung out with her
Aaron Hernandez yeah those types oh yeah
they'll hide the truck for them Nick
yeah yeah yeah right but nikkor and tate
or whatever that boy's name yes so i
can't i can't reach them right I love
them you can't get that urban urban oh
yeah I want my gaps audience we had the
Gary Owen audience yeah yeah you know so
you know I want to I you know I get a
lot of you think though overall I mean
in your also do what's what's it like
are black people and anyway getting
along you're getting wait no why your
face is chunky oh I'll probably have to
pop a few zits do you feel I'm serious
bro I need to get you but your Chi I see
you cheeks it's good really yeah you
funk you look gone earlier like a couple
of months ago he died from AIDS or
something
oh no yeah yeah but then he got he got
you know what kind of AIDS but it's no
Freddie Mercury a is the good kind
Oh singing yeah I'll take singing AIDS
any day worry that was your question
about the um how are blind people in
Asian people getting along what's going
on there I'm like what are you talking
about I'm just saying we tell you the
history of it
okay okay for many many years
Asians would open up liquor stores in
urban areas right and then like you know
accuse them of [ __ ] accuse him with the
Asians would accuse the black people
[ __ ] of what like taking now and laters
and stuff yeah or like you know no
browsing oh yeah can you touch you by oh
that kind of [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] I want
to pick up my handy my candy bar and
look at the [ __ ] you know calorie
count and [ __ ] yeah right so they would
do that black people and they will go
you touch you buy or you browse in
liquor stores you don't just go in and
go go right to the KitKat's Yeah right
maybe I want to look at the [ __ ] you
know uh you know did the coconut
right right coconut milk or so riot
lemon yeah that what happened was um
they were doing all that [ __ ] cuz I go
to this Korean spa before they wouldn't
even let black people in there but then
what happened was bro the riots and then
the rock and then the black people burn
liquor stores down yeah why just because
oh you bro you can be flammable yeah but
still what they did you know I mean they
burn it down to the ground but do tell
me if you guys are getting along I'm
gonna get to the history so then what
happened was dude then you know after
that Koreans softened right and then
after that right rush hour
came out yeah and then that we can solve
crimes together yeah Jackie Chan Jackie
Brown right we can like you know we
don't understand each other we're in the
cop car but we could still solve this
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah all that stuff so then
after that everything's cool now I like
that yeah you like that now somebody
said that um a black friend told me that
[Music]
Chinese people are like the black people
of Asia is that true or is that what is
that have you ever heard that
do you just say Chinese people are the
black people of Asia
yeah yeah aside from the fact they don't
have black dicks Chinese don't bro who's
going who got that large meat on the
Asian side Oh
Filipinos for sure mixed in with like
because the Spanish because they were
like invaded so much occupy bro that
like you hated enough you get out very
little right
yeah the Spanish look in the Filipino
hole oh you know babies are made oh yeah
yeah right
and they squirt inside right in the
third the buck dick oh right so you know
they were colonized places that
recolonize are mixed in with [ __ ] I wish
black African nations colonized more
yeah because maybe I'd have a bigger
dick if they if the black people they do
a little bit they have the Barclays
Center oh if you've seen that I've never
I've never had the ability to ask
someone who's Asian or semi Asian what
it's like to have like what that
relationship is like between black and
Asian people yeah I mean you know that
it's more hostile between Asians and
Asians brah really yeah I mean because
my dad growing up he gave me a list of
the best in our IP your dad man your dad
oh yeah thanks man but he used to give
me the list of the best ethnicities from
best to worst right so it went number
one was Korean because that's what we
are number two and went Japanese and
jeiza number three was like cockroach
right then four was yo5 with snakes or
nah brother that's real six donkeys
seven Mexicans right but out of he made
a list of a hundred black people weren't
even on the list yeah and they weren't
even on the list I my list is blacks
number one brah
yeah right so under Iverson right Allen
Iverson number one on sex not sex number
two regular nas regular right be Kim oh
yeah big kiss she was always big kid
bigad yeah but um no because that's you
so my dad comes from a generation of
Korean dudes and they had beef with
black people well they're number one
beef ultimately don't was with Japanese
and now you know because they they
tortured rest for 5060 years no way yeah
I'm really all broke my dad used to tell
me some stories that will [ __ ] her mind
up sorry about that what I didn't do it
no I'm just sorry that it happened I
feel bad that uh yeah I didn't know that
happened
yeah what do you mean I don't know the
history huh you was the most [ __ ] up
thing bro so the jab bro so the Japanese
right yeah occupied Korea for all that
time Japanese are very sneaky huh oh
they're the sneaky as Pearl Harbor brawl
yeah right they were sleeping that you
know mean right right they did all that
oh this sneaky little [ __ ] you know
we're calm sneaky chopsticks yeah
they're little cheeky chopsticks bro but
they make good ninjas that's why they do
huh yeah but I guess because they have
so much sneak in them big that's right
right and because I don't know why
they're the masks yeah why because you
know they all look the same right well
you're not gonna see a tree with a ninja
and go with no mask and go hey is that
Frank Yamamoto you know you're gonna go
no ninja whatever rides a guy yeah dude
um so here's the thing so okay
so the Japanese occupied Korea for um 50
60 years like really go over there and
they would take I swear to [ __ ] god
they would take all their rice oh and
that's her favorite yeah don't take our
rice it's like going to Italy and taking
their pasta yeah wearing your salt
coming in borrow my salt yeah right so
then what happened was a lot of Korean
families they went to Japan they took
their fan right back no to go where the
food was but then there was a lot of
Korean families when Hiroshima and
Nagasaki fell bro so they all died too
so imagine that but all right I can
imagine yeah we're what finally we found
the rise and they look up in the sky
holy [ __ ]
yeah real rice tonight yes God super
fried so but now everything's pretty
good between Asian cultures or what is
it like right now I think no I think
people are like what you know I used to
say certain things back in the day I got
in a lot of trouble bro the one thing I
said I said one time 15 years ago that
the Vietnamese were jungle Asians that's
all I said
AAA's they call them pull up a J see
what happens but then what happened was
dude I had to go to every Vietnamese
news outlet and do apologies oh really
yeah because it's like not right I don't
know what I don't know why jungle agent
is bad I think it sounds like the best
guy like you know the best kind by the
way yeah that's the thing no but like
here's the thing racism if you're
actually racist where you're out
throwing like a like us like a Lance at
somebody or you're you know opening up
their door and sneak you know a sword in
their frickin grandparents and [ __ ]
right no way but if you're just mildly
racist passing through town dude it's
not racism there's a certain level of
like hey it's okay to like joke around
about stuff get to your friends yeah you
can't like you know the other day I was
with what's that little black little
[ __ ] black guy that he was in the
Chappelle show oh why are you talking
about Donna Rosa now run yeah a little
dwarf a little dwarf he's getting taller
there we need what is he four left he's
five - yeah I know but he was four seven
so love yeah yeah we sprinkle water on
any grows right but that little [ __ ]
black guy right done now we were hanging
out and I said hey little man right
because he was really loud Yeah right
you know Kings that would Brad Williams
oh yeah all those little tribes yeah and
I got a little man and he was loud and I
go we're in a movie theater hmm and we
all laughed or whatever right it's a
stereotype yeah you know but you can't
go up to some random black guy in a
restaurant and say that yeah quiet down
in here you know yes a Bridges of
Madison
all right yeah which is actual for all
of that movie they do yeah do Marlon
Wayans his favorite movie what Bridges
of Madison County
in his second favor is Doctor Zhivago
bro really love epic romantic movies
Russian yeah but my point is is that
yeah what is it what I'm try to follow
you following me bro way I'm saying
though is we gotten so [ __ ] sensitive
in our society right and it's like you
know I gauge it based on because I have
a lot of black friends
white dudes like you you know you delete
you know Santino I have a lot of Asian
friends and we all amongst each other
you guys say the most racist [ __ ] to me
and I laugh because it's out of pure
love Yeah right and they've been doing
that back in the day you know I mean I
bet you back in India or like South
North South Africa when Indians were
there and all the people from Morocco
and they were they would make fun of
each other yeah they're having fun and
and it's like we cannot you know
nowadays you know you can't body shame
or nothing I think you can lightly body
shame I think here's somebody right here
as a question man and this is a young
man it listen it was he listening in or
no oh no but it's a very related okay
guy hey guys
all my groups our friends are quite
similar to your two to yours in terms of
we we always make fun of each other we
tease each other we're very close but
there's always teasing going around but
there are a certain topics that are
off-limits for jokes
you know like dead relatives so we don't
really joke about like on ourselves so I
was kind of wondering whether your
groups of friends you know are there any
topics are off limits in terms of jokes
and yeah are they only talk is you
basically stay away from when you do
joke around thanks gang gang brother
gang gang brother what's Gang Gang Gang
means it just means that we're together
as a group and that we are we're all
good okay good yeah thank you
yeah man first of all that guy's an
accent and I want to say this Bobby I
wanna this is on behalf of a couple of
different nations that I went to
recently
there is people that are really wanting
to see you in other countries no yeah I
was just saying I know I agree with you
Bobby I'm just saying no the number one
person they asked for puppy I'll tell
you something right now right bro they
all wanted it bro give us Bobby yeah
but here's the thing my fear is is that
I'm gonna go you're gonna you're gonna
say go to Germany I go there three
people show up you know and then you're
gonna be laughing here in LA I don't
trust it
I need the science and the data brah
yeah I am the data bro I come I come
bearing data they want you Bobby there's
people coming up to me in Scotland like
who do I call huh yeah call Connor yeah
Darren till call the Embassy yeah it
says one jacker where were you free
computer you'll help me out with that or
no bro they will want you I'm not joking
everybody Zack where's Bobby send him
over telling me love okay okay okay the
most requested thank you yeah yeah I'll
go back to this [ __ ] no okay yeah this
beautiful guy he's from another country
right could be anywhere
I see here's the thing to me to me I do
yeah I don't know why I just said it
that way and that's him right there is
there a guy from a lord of the stones or
whatever what is it called lord of the
dance
no that's the dude from bleachers he's
the lead singer Lord Lord of the know uh
Harry Potter Harry no Lord of the Rings
ranks Lord of the Rings yes or the Rings
bro that's a good directly yeah Lord of
the Ring what I want to know I'll tell
you what he wants to know cuz is
anything off limits with your friends
with our friends so here's the deal bro
mm-hmm you you know you know how was a
molested by a guy with Down syndrome
yeah there's one of my favorite things
about you honestly because I can relate
to it right but when if you could you
make fun of me with that you know I'm
open to it correct but you don't make
fun of my dead dad because he just died
right so but how long after he's dead
can you talk about next week
hey do it next week but do you though
but do you feel like we use humor as a
way for like well there's two things I
want to talk about first of all let's
answer that let me answer the guys
question do we think that there's things
that are off-limits I think calling some
of the n-word is off-limits 100 percent
okay yeah because it's like there's
nothing funny about it and if you call a
Jewish person a money in word I think
that yeah yeah yeah but I think wigger
is good
I think workers good some guy hit me up
on Twitter the other day yeah I think
wicker is okay I think it's okay I think
I think anything with that you can call
white people is okay yeah cracker is
okay because you guys don't have a lot
of [ __ ] things we can call you I
don't like redneck though I think it's
kind of offensive a little bit but yeah
but that's also it's not really my coat
it's not my your walk redneck yeah I
mean I'm yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah it
just never really was in that do you no
but it's not like that that you've been
the Nash five been in a show I've been
to the South bro
they're all [ __ ] like us they're just
like a it's just like us that's the
thing nobody like the news always makes
them like everybody's all like at each
other's nobody's really like that yeah
do you know what I've been um
soul-searching you know me because um
you know I I automatically hate anybody
that likes Trump for instance like a
real hot button issue for me is it
really it used to be but I've been like
kind of stepping back at it and go you
know I don't know why people I don't
know I've never been in their shoes I
don't know what their lives are like or
what brought them to the point where
they like the guy they might see
qualities that I'm just not aware of or
whatnot and I'm gonna accept the fact
that they're like that yeah I mean and
just you know it is what it is
that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're a bad person or that um you know
cuz a lot of them like a look and the go
Trump 20/20 but then they'll have like
they're really tender with animals yeah
right so it's like it's not you know
it's not black and white for me now no
it's not as black and white as people
that we're thinking that that kind of
stuff is yeah it's like um I know let me
I know somebody on this wall who I think
is
gay mm-hmm okay let me look who it no no
we're not doing that right now Lisa at
that's him how do you know that but what
I'm saying is oh I know who it is dude
right right so but you know it's
somebody that doesn't want to share that
information so and it's I don't I would
never bring it up or prod this woman
yeah you know I mean so my point is is
that any with you
bill birnes wife yeah that's it is it
yeah full blown lez Wow yeah but my
point is is that so you know
instinctually first of stephanas
daughter yeah no okay go on
no are there things that you have
thought about making fun of me about but
you thought that I would be hurt by it
no I say those things like Oh someone
else a dude I'm gonna drop you off at
every American Legion or every like VFW
around America you know yeah and let's
see those boys finish the war you know
share ideas that I have right and for me
dude I ain't being meas right right so I
get there a joke right it's like you
know dice Andrew Dice Clay for 25 years
he called me Ching yeah right and one
day I just a sound or like an Asian
slower you I don't know
Ching I don't think Ching is great kind
of right right but I wonder I he goes
you know my name right this is after 15
years my name is Bobby you know that
right because yeah what I thought you
but you call me Ching and he goes it's
as chi-ching your money why and so the
cycle it's fine yeah yeah so it's like I
know where people's hearts it now if
somebody call me Ching and they were
hanging me by a rope yeah on a tree or
putting out a bunch of stuff to make a
railroad I mean Santino [ __ ] building
[ __ ] yeah yeah
Chingy are of Chingy what if it was
Chingy the rapper that'd be fine yeah
where's Chingy I'll look it up I have a
question about it we were gonna do a
segment on King in the sting where we
people sent in their tattoos and they
tell us about it and Brendan and Theo
would roast it and we want to call it
[ __ ] my
Inc I did nothing to do with race yeah
it's like you find the chinks in my in
my ink yeah yeah it's fine it's fine
because there's no Asians there that's
what I said
yeah so did you air it like that no
there was some internal strife some
people a couple of people on the email
chain kind of put pro pro pro pro but
check it out probably check it out
the reason [ __ ] [ __ ] check it out
the reason why I feel [ __ ] yeah did
podcasts to begin with is to be free
right because the thing is is that I've
done every aspect of show biz yeah rice
gating do you ever do you ever did show
skating did you you you know what I
[ __ ] mean by it yeah dude you spread
your fingers farther apart if you're
gonna talk to me no but my point is I've
carpal you do yeah bro I could easily
see yeah but my point is is that the
reason why I [ __ ] did a podcast is to
be utterly free yeah right and so if
we're now editing and listening to a
board or groups of people and you can't
say this than that then we're not
exercising is all right to say whatever
we [ __ ] want to we're all right so
it's like [ __ ] that yeah [ __ ] that dude
what are you talking about again what
was the shrink in this [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the ink and we're Ching is right now
yeah Chingy yeah yeah my point is you
get what I'm saying right yeah you know
what not to do so the guide no you know
what is that Chingy right here I've
never heard of ching-he what is he
saying right right right Thur oh hes a
qtpie home because the guy was given
directions to somebody and they just put
a beat to it I don't even know what that
Joe Weber was funny right Burks ah yeah
right
he was good man ching he's good oh yeah
maybe he's been producing he's got a
beautiful picture of his children there
yeah I don't do that's the thing I don't
I don't know much about the the rap game
yeah you know I was I grew up listening
to rock and roll and that was strictly
that so I feel shame yeah you don't the
other day somebody says you got to
listen to the door oh but it got big
mm-hmm my tour is big yeah take mataró
take the car Tara and I listened to her
album man it was real [ __ ] hit long
good the flavor was good streets no like
I was listening tutorials big IB IG for
the first time you know ever and I loved
it yeah right and I've been listening to
like ja Rule no the guy that died that
was friends with beak Beyonce no no [ __ ]
oh I knew it is Shane Randolph
that's him dude Shane Randolph dude that
guy could throw down I think I saw him
one time um in concert not in person but
there's someone wanted to ask you about
Bobby so what's up yeah rolling in here
with this [ __ ] fake ass haircut do
that shit's kind of weak you know bro
okay you say something bro yeah of
course you're gonna say it we would I
say just this is something I say I did
[ __ ]
yeah yeah why I did shift cuz you came
in here here's a question right here
from somebody who's obviously from the
past dude from the 17 or 18 Hunter his
brother Scott obviously oh sure he's
from the revenant bro yeah his name is
grimy gross yeah yeah do you know what
this one got show up with a boat on your
show the [ __ ] is up with that dude oh
listen what you ask them well is there
when he's gonna come through and do a
show of the rotten apple get Bobby down
New York and be greatly appreciated keep
it up gang gang bro I will say this big
Jay oakerson has taken much better care
of I will easily say that yeah yeah dude
wouldn't you gonna go places man what is
your fear of going places they want you
in Europe you're like I don't know man
something I'm in an anthill
this guy wants you yeah [ __ ] that guys
got about a Bing guy man let's talk
about that guy look at the slips road
they're so luscious yeah that guy's a
legend bro yeah takes care of his skin
oh if he was a woman I would eat his
[ __ ] look at that nose lips so juicy my
point is is this dude I I don't go then
I said I don't go bro where I'm not
wanted but you're wanted for bro from
one guy let me say this do
I when I was in New York for week four
months years ago yeah I play Gordo
Gotham get your there right did you buy
a cheap calendar from some dobro four
years ago I went to Gotham you're like I
was your Foreman for George Foreman I
wanna say this and I did five shows
there mm-hmm the [ __ ] third show six
people showed up yeah right so I'm not
gonna go there humiliate myself they
want you in Ireland bar they want you in
London I brought you in Afghanistan they
want you in Qatar they want you they do
it with you in Cairo bro or how about
this friend I will go to these places
okay but the consequences if no one
shows up is gonna be very deep for you
bro
bring it on dude no dude I'm being real
dude you're there already look you're
over there you got my haircut
just take it man see they can't ever bro
you want the studio take it man this you
know what my next one is gonna be bro
what dreadlocks a friend is it yeah do
love that I'm gonna do a dreadlock thing
you know I'm looking you black our own
oh yeah yeah I could see blacking up a
little yeah um what's going on with the
UH with the old lady how's everything
good why you asking cuz she's beautiful
lady I just thought I would ask you as a
question when hear from somebody who
looks like they've been home alone a lot
I love in cells what up yeah I'm from
the great white north Canada gang Bob
questions for Bobby what is the most
unforgivable thing you've ever done
okay gang gay this is gonna be good
III might get I might get um I can't say
it you get cancelled no I think this the
one unforgivable thing that I've done
there was retribution I did suffer the
consequences of it but um it's a pretty
long story but um I don't know if I can
tell it because when I told at one time
they had to cut it out you know it's
that illegal but it's it's is it like
Brad Williams a story which
that he told on the Burton bill burr
pocket what'd he do the end of the
rainbow and nobody's old slot over he
was in with Gerald what's-his-name he's
looking a bad sleepover with uh honest
not Carlos Mencia it's not oh no no no
mines way worse bro
okay um Wow uh all right you know what
maybe I could tell it without the
details you wanted a lot without the
details you want it or not do it you
it's on my terms bro without the details
bro I'll take it then
oh yeah that's Brad he apologized for
that what'd he do hey hello everyone I
just read it he did what is known in
some circles as the David Blaine uh-huh
yeah he's apparently he said on a
podcast he made up a story on a podcast
hitting high with Doug on getting Howard
Doug that he had in that he had gone
into he was working on a tour Carlos
Mencia and he went in and there was a
girl who's gonna hook up with Carlos on
the bus and instead Carlos sent Brad in
and Brad went in and had sex with the
girl yeah and for like ten minutes she
didn't know that it was Brad she thought
it was Carlos she also sucked the bus
drivers off to get on the bus allegedly
did he make sure the name of the woman
this fake woman no so how is that in
trouble well it was just people and then
Eddie IFFT goes well that's like
technically rape you know if you go in
and you have sex with somebody that
doesn't know you're gonna have sex with
them you know ah came like a stink yeah
well first of all no one's gonna believe
that story right when you be saying I
Brett I was like princess Leah and I was
in space and I was able to fly around
right when you go back and watch the
story it's I believe it's obvious to any
viewer or listener that oh he's making
this up especially when you visually
watch it and the question was named
something crazy that happened when you
were on the road with Carlos Mencia so I
was like searching that yeah right so he
made something up because we were under
pressure yeah I've done that before oh
you can see him do it yeah you can see
and be like I don't know what
to tell and then he made up the story it
definitely seemed made up but people
like tripped on him for it really yeah
well then let me try to approach this
story delicately okay okay
growing up I was unfuckable mm-hmm right
I was I grew up in Poway high school you
grew up in a beautiful area of San Diego
I did okay yeah but a lot of white
people women didn't want you in Vietnam
why weren't you somewhere
why weren't you closer to the [ __ ]
locust [ __ ] you dude you know why bro
it's like saying go hug to a black guy
how come you were in Nigeria I just was
born here okay I don't have no [ __ ]
toy okay
that's all right I have no [ __ ]
choice Robert no I might know if you
guys had come over for something or if
you were I was on like a foreign
exchange thing dude out my pet I was
born you know out of my mom's puss
yeah yeah right and I was it happened to
happen in Sharpe hospital in San Diego
oh yeah yeah American citizen yeah yeah
all day every day yeah that's what
that's what they do
so growing up in that environment dude
and I was a horndog you're mean I like
to stick my dick in trees were you
really yeah I would run back against
tree out there I would come on things we
had to grow I can see that yeah like
trees and flowers and we'll get that
thing inside he that wants to get out
right and when I was in high school
there was this thing called the Sadie
Hawkins dance no one ever asked me yeah
so then I and I graduated and I just had
coffee shop jobs you're no money I could
see you with a broom in a coffee shop
yeah you know I made coffee too as well
yeah sure after you've been there for a
couple months I can see with the broom
in the beginning yeah in the beginning
yeah yeah yeah by the end you're like
the coffee guy before you yeah so what
happened was I worked at this restaurant
oh yeah yeah as a waiter bro I started
off as a broom guy yeah and I got up
became a waiter brah
and every Wednesdays it was Tijuana
Wednesday's know what that means uh-uh
Mexican no
no do all the waiters we take our tip
money and go to Adelita you know what a
Talitha is it's for a prostitute it's a
prostitute it's a it's a brothel in
Tijuana still exist or Aires because
they're all the time I think it does
yeah yeah yeah here's their peers
excessive poster on his wall from there
it's great of a gift shop unless people
love it there right yeah it's crazy
yeah and so well do people ever think
that do do dumb people ever think that
you're Mexican anyway uh that's
ridiculous bro yes because I was on that
TV but which one is it it's ridiculous
or the answer is yes yes I do think I'm
next yeah easily yeah I could easily see
somebody few driving by on a truck or
something you're going to leave already
five miles and I'm like oh there's a
Mexican guy and I'll roll down my window
I go you you go Raiders and you die
right hey bro what's happening to you
would be a good Mexican hey dude what's
happening so anywhere brah right i one
day went there with my crew my way to
crew and all this military was there so
all the women were taking up oh yeah
scary military dudes around you got a
really chill out all right [ __ ] this is
gonna be a hard story to tell man I
don't know if I can get around it I'll
try it you want to try yeah I'll tell
you one out of one after the line though
if I say this story and you think
honestly if you think this is gonna ruin
me will you cut it out yes I will you
promise me yes
why did you roll your eyes brah I didn't
I was looking around the room really
fast right so these are things that I
don't know for a fact but in back of
Adalia there used to be an alleyway
hooker alley
oh yeah and so there were used to be
girls that were too fat to go into
Adelina oh really yeah Wow or women that
like are virgins
oh okay newbies newbies right so there
was this crime huh right so I was
walking down hook er alley and there was
a girl what
to get a girl okay yeah yeah if you're
just wandering around [ __ ] you no no
no no I was like and when you walk down
hooker alley because I'm some of them
were really old they'll go you know
Meester they'll grab you the gummy
string Eastern Eastern let me see the
cookie right and then you go you go
don't touch me I'm an American like that
oh damn
yeah I would do that right mister let me
see that little here yellow baby yeah
but at the end there was a little peepee
yeah there was a girl that she seems
scared yeah that's what I wanted oh why
was it Halloween or something yeah man I
was wearing my chupacabra mask oh yeah
like that right but she seems scared
wrong damn so I picked her you did yeah
yeah because you looked up now look at
the context of it I never get laid right
this is the only way I get laid oh this
is in 1992-93 long time ago oh wow long
times a lot of people listening right
wasn't even born yet yeah a lot of
people with and this is a different time
this is a time in prostitution was king
really alright I ride with a king right
so um I took her to this place called
Miami hotel mm-hmm it's the kind of
place you ever Moo see the movie se7en
nah is it like a double tree yeah yeah
yeah it's actually a movie about the
Double Tree bro I've stated it no no I
know sevens about Brad Pitt yeah yeah
but it's it's grimy it's got you know
it's got those you know those yellow
things that stick down the sticky stuff
to catch the flies oh yeah right and
yeah it's got all those like pine cone
air fresheners on the ceilings dangling
down the floor was super sticky yeah
right dark and there was like a
bulletproof glass and in they go you
want a rule and you go yeah how much $10
bro $10 you get $10 you'll have a door
on it or not there's no door you know
how they get in there how many there
were did armor release up a motel bus
and you would pay as probably maybe set
$16 for the room yeah it was $2 for the
door
really yeah
the door you could bring your own door
but it's the odds of it fitting and they
would purposely make it a different
shape a little bit like an inch off from
like a basic door you know from your
basic yeah thoroughfare template you
know yeah this is so shameful so we go
in there they give you a condom and or
they give you a condom yeah but it's
like Tijuana condom right so it's gum
right they chew gum it was just some guy
standing there like like a crossing
guard like right so then you know I um
we go into the darkroom I stick and
how's the woman feeling is she what is
she wearing is she I don't really
remember what she's wearing I think she
was wearing like a Hello Kitty shirt you
know I mean oh well then that's I'm not
saying that that's sexually suggestive
yeah but first of all why for kids you
can't put them in something called Hello
Kitty she's not expect perverts to show
us this is not a kid meant as an adult
good good this is an adult so don't say
kid
I didn't you in the beginning knit do
you think he it sound like he was
talking about a kid or an adult who I
think he said girl which is ambiguous
but okay
woman I'm glad only girl woman bro good
you get get me oh it's all I get
okay good okay so then I stick the
condom on then we make you know pure
love okay but then what happened was and
what stymie are you guys kind of Angry
like stop grooving with it cool as a cat
okay any music on or in my head yeah
yeah or you know what another one is
like Ritchie Valens yeah the English
part of Feliz Navidad oh yeah yeah I
wanna wish you a Merry Christmas you
know me I don't do the Feliz Navidad
part in my head yeah yeah yeah that's a
great song by the way probably the best
Christmas tune on planet Earth
really you think that yeah because it's
for two different cultures and I like
being clean all that I like Vince Vance
and the valiance they make over they
have a beautiful really really in it so
then you know I'm making sweet love to
her and there's so now there's a crack
in the window what is it the curtains is
closed but the moon is bright right so
it's shining through this the new year
or anything is it like this Chinese New
Year yeah right so the crack and you see
the light it hits her face and I look at
her face and she's crying oh it's not
bubbles old thing No ah yeah so I feel
bad you know I'm a good guy right yeah
bad so I do what any good guy would do I
start power [ __ ] in yeah so cuz I
want to get it over with
oh I see so you starts more just having
sex at a higher rate is how I mean you
could say it that way nobody's ever
looked at you and be like oh yeah that
guy okay bro you seem like a guy that
has that more like mousetrap [ __ ] like
one yeah yeah yeah Susan I just I come
real quick I put my clothes back I run
out I didn't say goodbye okay so that's
part one the second part of the story I
call God's revenge oh wow you want to
hear that you want to hear God's revenge
we do right after this commercial break
oh I hate to interrupt this episode man
I'm really enjoying my time here with a
little Robert but I got to tell you that
better help is a place that can help
people like me and people like little
Robert better help will assess your
needs and match you with a licensed
professional therapist if you you don't
want to you don't want to park in the
parking lot of a therapist you don't
want you're afraid of who you might see
in the hallway um you're afraid maybe of
a spouse or or of a a brother or young
visitor knowing that you are getting
help for yourself then better help may
be an option for you better help allows
you to contact a therapist and get
timely and thoughtful responses through
weekly video or phone sessions so you
won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better he'll want
you to start living a happier life today
it's available to clients
worldwide it's not a crisis line it's
not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online and
right now you can visit better help.com
slash Theo
that's btter h ELP and join the over
500,000 people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional special offer
this past weekend listeners get 10% off
your first month at Vetter help.com
slash Theo that's ten percent off your
first month of help for yourself at
better help.com slash Theo I've pulled
over in my car and gotten on real-time
FaceTime and had a conversation with a
therapist through better help it is
there when you need it better help calm
slash Theo and now back to the episode
hey there
today's episode is brought to you by
something I like to tell you about and
that thing is skill share everybody you
know you don't have you're looking for
something you can't find it and that's
because you don't have the skill to find
things you might be wanting to do a kite
or do baseball or do make cement and do
outdoor side walking but you can't do it
because you don't know how to
well skill share is a place for skills
make 2020 a year where you explore new
skills or deepen existing passions get
lost in creativity all with skill shares
online classes what you find just might
surprise and inspire you
I'm personally taking Simon cynics how
to share ideas that inspire action skill
share offers classes designed for real
life so you can move your creative
journey forward without putting your
life on hold
you can log on and take the classes
whenever you want at your own pace all
you have to have is some commitment to
your own program you can take classes in
film and video music and music
production
productivity and finance explore your
creativity at skill shared calm / Theo
von right now and get two free months of
premium membership that's two months
free at Skillshare dot-com / Theo von
explore your creativity at Skillshare
calm / Theo von - free months see what
skills they have and we're back for it
sorry I just I've never done that for
you know that so well bro what are you
doing down there why did you go down
there what to the brothel why are you in
this Bobby because the thing is is that
I can't get women back then this is way
before I did stand up
well what about Stevie is he of women oh
no he's in sell to a friend right my
brother little brother but you know he
got more than that mom is she letting
y'all come over - even to spend time at
the house or anything like you guys
aren't even getting any kind of TLC or
anything no nothing brah nothing why
yeah dude it was hard but dude it this
is the event the second part of the
story is the event of what drove me into
doing stand-up really okay so I go back
down there do you remember her name no
bro I don't even know what's the hook
size no I don't know her name look like
the bad guy yeah a little bit let's give
her an easy okay Stacy yeah it's a tasty
yeah so it's tasty I go to find Stacy
again two weeks later hmm so you had a
nice time I just like Stacy okay right I
thought we had a thing going I thought
you said you were she was disappointed
she was okay so what'd he do this Bob so
i go to i go i go to hooker alley and
there's no one there huh I don't know
what happened what was it was it a
holiday you mean Martin Luther King Day
I mean was it a holiday was there any I
don't [ __ ] remember bro this is no
one there that day bro what are you
maybe was right tamale festival may go a
mile down I don't know Brock driving
three hours to Mexico you
aha well I'm in San Diego at the time oh
yes I have 20 minute drive Tiffany
doesn't stand up yet no I just said that
well age are you 21 mmm 20 21 okay but
at the end of hooker alley is this
redheaded albino not kidding you
dwarf Hispanic kid hold on a second let
me add all these things up yeah redneck
Albine redheaded sorry redheaded albino
I wore not kidding you brought her from
a David Lynch movie bra dwarf Hispanic
albino yeah Wow anything a you as a blue
seas Wow more than one yeah I go wow he
said a plural so I go yeah I like
[ __ ] mmm you some goop Bulls yeah
follow me so I followed this [ __ ] guy
how long do you take the following small
guys if you follow a small guy did it
takes twice as long exactly so it was
three blocks so uh seven hours well I
don't laugh stash for one block well why
don't you just tell me where to go and
I'll get there all right you know to be
rude he goes this is my friend Raul so
we meet this other dude and he's like
six - oh yeah skinny tats - his wrist he
looks scary braum and he's wearing like
a like a weird black overcoat thing is
he spanish as well
yeah he's Mexican okay like a bull she's
he says Oh same thing you know they both
other yeah they know each other
follow me so I follow these [ __ ] guys
12-block I'm not kidding you oh my but
it gets to the point where there's no
more street lights huh tumbleweed
three-legged dogs walking around and I'm
now going I think I'm in trouble which I
was I was in big trouble so he sees this
gay we see this gate and it ruie so he
opens the gay and did it seem was there
any art outside was there any like thing
where it's like oh this is Leah Shepard
Fairey painting on the wall with the
[ __ ] about anything that lead you to
believe there is women there so you see
no not very nothing
okay nothing nice so as soon as he I
walked through this alleyway the little
man just takes off running oh my god and
then I go where the [ __ ] and then by the
time that thought happens now I'm up
against a wall and this dude because
this guy put this a tall guy pushed me
against the wall and he takes out a
[ __ ] machete and he sticks against my
throat he goes give me a money so that I
cook you know brother for sex or not no
bro okay well you're not giving us any
yeah you it's at some chance bro they're
gonna be no [ __ ] I know there's no
[ __ ] okay right so that was a red
herring so there's no fish there so the
truth is though this man wants to be a
robber that's what he is he's a criminal
oh my god so that he sticks that so I
give him the money bro I had like 250
bucks
oh yeah Wow a lot of money back then why
I had $200 in 1995 Nick where you looked
that up please okay so the guy has you
against the wall off that knife knife so
he so he has a knife right and he pulls
the money and he sticks my wallet it
throws him it was I were distinctly
remember there's a puddle mm-hmm where
my wallet was and I'm thinking how could
I give him the money I was gonna leave
no then he grabs my hair and he sticks
the [ __ ] machete to my throat and he
proceeds to cosplay me
nah yeah he cut your throat no right
when I feel the sharp blade like him
pushing in I hear two other voices down
this alleyway I never was that the
checks or not no there's no [ __ ] bro
okay okay it was hopeful it was plus
four hundred nineteen dollars and 39
cents you gave the guy okay so I give
400 right but I also work at a really
nice restaurant oh yeah it's nothing
take that out anyway
but my point is so then these two other
dudes right yeah they go and they're
with now the dwarf showed up back up
mm-hmm he was there too with these guys
and they're fighting no what are they
fighting about that you we want a piece
of the money I heard dinero whatever
right
this is our alleyway what the [ __ ] you
doing we want some of that money and
what is it what are you thinking about
escaping like what do you know I of
course bro no I want to have tea yeah
yeah yeah no I so as soon as he the guy
releases me huh I go down I'm a little
and also back then I will you fat like
you were heard do you think I don't know
I do at that time I was skinny and fast
yeah right so I grab the wallet and I
start running in the all four of them
start chasing after me now I'm running
like Carl Lewis through these streets
bro you pretty fast or not you're pretty
fast then then I was and also your
adrenaline and your life is at stake
dude I mean trust me dude
something came over me dude I was
zipping but they were fast as [ __ ] bro -
right and they're chasing me through a
zig zagging through all these streets
just imagine going through these corners
right running and then I see this corner
cement everywhere sometimes in Mexico
you're in weird area there's like
suddenly there's a piece of cement like
what the FRA
right a lot of potholes yeah difficult
to run right yeah but then I see in this
corner this pink awning with a neon sign
blinking and I go that's a business
something and I run toward it and then
the Lord presented himself to me 30
black Marines walk out of this [ __ ]
bar and I run toward them I'm in America
I mean I'm an American these guys are
trying to kill me I'm good you know I
mean that whole [ __ ] thing wrong and
then a buddy would walk you through the
border buddy Wow so two of them walked
me to the [ __ ] border dude right
number one I never went back except to
get drugs later when I relapsed but I
never went back to get [ __ ] yeah ice
that was that done for me Yeah right
and number two
maybe a year later I started to stand up
but it was the event that made me go you
gotta do something with your life bro
right come on life it yep sometimes all
day oh yeah this kind of behavior and
this kinda this cut is not me and it's
not the lifestyle I want to live right
and so um you know a year later I was
walking down the La Jolla Comedy Store
there to help want it signed and I
knocked on it and I could can I get a
job here so in 9,000 1994 and then I
worked it for a while and then in 95 I
did open mic so that was like a catalyst
for really kind of like just yes
sometimes you have those events that
show you okay this is what's going on
with you right now this is where you're
at
is this where you really want to be yeah
it's like yeah and you know what I'm a
human being and I make mistakes and you
know I also have a you know I'm a I've
been in and out of sobriety all my life
you know I started doing crystal
methamphetamine at twelve oh yeah right
so I've always even because of my dad's
trauma I my dad used to beat the [ __ ]
out of me mo no I'm being real like my
brother and I my mind yeah why would I
do that
he did we get here King a [ __ ] golf
club and he thought at five six seven
years old so I have all this PTSD and
trauma and then at 12 I start doing
drugs because I needed to find relief oh
definitely and then at 17 I got sober
but my point is is that you know I've
you know since I was born I've had a
rocky thing you know and luckily at 23 I
was still sober and i am i found
stand-up and it was literally literally
three months a miracle happen i when you
were a doorman at the Comedy Store and
you were doing stand-up what they would
do is they would go on Saturday nights
if you'd or you can host either the
first or second Channel and there was
two dormant so you would choose this
time I get the first one it's like ah
great opportunity straight on stage
that's how I met Mencia that's where I
met Pauly that's how I met all these
guys that are friends with still today
why did um did black did who's the
did Richard Pryor ever come through or
now yeah I'll tell you that in a second
but um what happened was one Saturday
night I was on stage and this is when
Prince and Princess Diana died oh yeah I
remember that right I have a good
friends as Diana story right and um I
remember um this girl crying after the
show this beautiful white girl and he
was Jennifer just blue eyes tan and what
you do have sex with her know what I
said what I touched her back and I she
was crying and going crying he's after
the show she goes it Princess Diana dies
I don't know it's just really you know I
go oh I'm sorry for your loss well
that's it something right and then I was
sweeping up you know with the mom yeah
after the club and the manager goes hey
Lee Fred burns we used to manage club
you got phone call and it was the girl
and she goes hey I live in Oceanside
come over and I went over there and so
granted I've never had regular girls
before right and I remember 16 her mom
was out of towners on that we 69 in her
mom's closet
oh my and I remember I remember her ass
smell the shoes too
I love being in somebody's mom's car you
can smell their [ __ ] nice high heels
and stuff in there
it wasn't a memory that was lodged into
my head okay okay but I do remember as a
cold in there kind of that's another
another thing another experience that I
don't recall okay okay
but I remember grabbing or cheeks and
you know you 16 I'm always the bottom I
never do top yeah yeah yeah yeah because
then you have that your mouth [ __ ]
her I don't like it yeah who goes
upstairs I've ever seen that you're
right it's always the bottom my bad
that's insane Broncos right but I
remember grabbing her cheeks yeah
and looking up at you know not the sky
but the ceiling but that God and I
remember going with a cure in my eye
yeah
and that fills up most of your eye
because I'm Asian that's true yeah
that's not racist no well people don't
think that yeah you get a tear man you
you know what I'm saying you're a third
waterlog do you [ __ ] you're halfway
through the Titanic movie right now
right I get one I can still [ __ ] him
he'll be snowmobile alright play tennis
whatever right yeah so I was like I said
thank you God you know I mean oh by the
way with AI jokes mm-hmm can I just say
this as a side note yeah I love him you
know me it's like one time I did a photo
shoot for a magazine in the photographer
was white and he said something kind of
races into media because hey we need
more expression in your eyes I go what
the [ __ ] bro that's what I said
there's like two things I do open and
close bro this is happy said angry and
it made everyone laugh I love I joke
yeah you know it's always your van I'll
people always call me Chinese and China
boy okay yeah yeah and mizar kind of
slanted too and one of my is that even
match the other one because you're an
old dad that's why it's genetic
something I don't know what is your
dad's come [ __ ] you up I think I mean I
don't want to think about that that's
crazy I don't think my but semen coming
out of my father I know but your dad was
old right yeah but in it crazy that
we're all semen what you mean Dawg I'm
just saying we are all semen yeah dude I
got semen inside me is that what you
mean but that we started off as semen
that's crazy
there was other things going on with
that you know we had to go inside the
over all right there's a lot going on I
believe you got to hit that overall is
if that's if that's true that we could
just Nick nut in a you know a petri dish
and just pour warm water and maybe it'll
grow well do you ever get nervous that
when you're ejaculating a lot of women
now will hold it and sneak off and use
it you know or they'll save it real
quick another person like a heating
environment and then get rid of it later
so I never heard of that before my life
what's going on let you so what you're
saying to me is this right I'm 69 a
woman I'm on top no nobody just let them
give you the scenario I'm on top and I'm
you know I mean that comment or do you
say mouth mm-hmm that's so crude yeah
look at nothing he heard them
the stuff that's already been bright so
she's now yeah right she has it her
mom's on her breath you write and then
you go hey I'm gonna go pee and then and
then she spits it in a you know warm
container and then she uses as a baby
yeah and then that's amazing
well is it crazy because right here we
have an article and it says woman keeps
sperm from oral sexual encounter uses to
get pregnant man sues Wow an appeals
court said a man can press a claim for
emotional distress after learning a
former lover had used his sperm to have
a baby
but he can't claim theft the ruling said
because the sperm were hers to keep Wow
why by the illinois appellate court
since dr. richard o phillips distressed
case back to the trial court they don't
want to deal with it they moved it back
but there's a ridiculous thing to sue
for because i would say that that's
right if you stole my toenail like clip
my nails and you i had just left them on
the table right and then you took it
right that's yours
but what if your toenails had little use
inside of them and I took them and
created those little use how would you
feel about it like you cloned me based
you took the DNA from the toenail well
that's exactly what this lady's doing
she's taking that I think that there's
there's a way I think that like bro you
just have to be conscious like for
instance you nut in the mouth and you
look and you go I need to see you spit
it out or swallow oh my god right now
we're all where is it went Michigan's
you said she's that where are you if you
goes mmm like that then what I do is I
go alright it achieves a spits out like
that that's mine you're right you have
to be more conscious I'm just saying
it's getting down to it right where
people are about cloning dobra okay
because some Chinese dude just got
arrested for cloning humans we're at his
apartment I made a little apartment
right let me ask you something right if
you can clone a human bro then with the
idea of God are we creating men then or
is God creating the man gods create him
were you
here duplicate and anybody can make a
Xerox machine you know what I'm saying
like we already did that right we can
clone other stuff but only the only guy
with the real blueprint is God you know
that's good I like that that's good
because now because in my head cuz you
know I believe in a God because of my
12-step journey I believe in a God yeah
yeah so for me it's like I don't want
anything to interfere with it but that
was [ __ ] me out bro
the cloning really yeah yeah because
it's like if we could create things on
our own now in a whim right it takes
time but we you know we have the
technology to do it
then there is no God because we're doing
it but the things we're gonna clone are
not gonna be as high quality do you're
gonna clone some real bootleg [ __ ] you
know all right like the meat yeah you're
gonna have like Bobby Lee right you know
you're gonna have like Bobby leek and
it's just some guy who's just walking
around and just is leaking all it's
right right this guy's wet okay like
we're there's gonna be faulty it's not
gonna fully happen you're not gonna get
the best quality yeah yeah you're gonna
get secondary meat I will say this that
the Japanese now or you can send them
your hair and they will grow a whole
crop of it and send it back to you can
you look that up Nicholas please yeah
man this is wild when I learned about
this yeah but back in that with the
suing the woman dude that reminds me bro
check this out before we get into this
if we don't mind yeah is that [ __ ]
there was a Chinese dude that married
another Asian lady but she had plastic
surgery okay right so she looked really
pretty but genetically she was ugly oh
right so then what happened was dude
they had kids and the kids were ugly so
he he divorced her what do you think of
that morally it breaks my heart but it's
like what else you gonna do because you
can't just get the surgery on the
children so then you have to arrive I
can't believe it's like like it was a
Diddy I wonder if he knew that she had
had plastic surgery he masada no no you
didn't know yeah he was deceived so yeah
I guess now we have to go look at
people's faces woman's yeah if we would
have a baby dude
f'hace yeah or is that your real [ __ ]
yeah you know the real face yeah show me
the real face
yeah and I'll base it on the phone yeah
let me see that first face you see
anything that I see like here
replication here replication and stuff
but not like an article that really said
it says it all happens in Japan I'm
looking for my point though is is that
you can still do it without growing it
my point is is this what you're saying
to me is that these Japanese fools hmm
right have the technology to grow hair
based on our hair right you can send
them a hair and they will send you back
an entire you know like a little half
acre so then what you have just your
hair next to the [ __ ] cactus trip
yeah then you get it installed in your
head oh that's oh so that's what you're
saying but we do we put in the baby's
room if you want me you can do whatever
you want with you right a certain amount
what I was gonna do with it is that just
make it like a pee rug for my [ __ ]
dog well would you would do it's
probably you would just take my hair and
then and just make yours just like mine
is exactly what you would do company
uses patient's own cells to put an end
to baldness aging skin and tendon
degeneration I don't think that's it
so that sounds better to me better
tendons because look at Pauly Shore
mm-hmm you didn't that's his real hair I
don't know it's a tiny bit sassy
gripping he you know he got me back here
he took those out mm-hmm and then plug
them in the flow I've had that you did
that yeah did it twice when let me see
one slide two years ago and then once
this year because I hurt months ago does
it hurt uh it doesn't feel like super
yeah yeah you know what I'm gonna do
what get my hair colored implants beard
implants okay
burns on my thighs that'd be pretty cool
dude I never thought of that so what are
you gonna get full beard put in there
but you gives it yeah because you know I
have my number I have my 60 or a look on
lockdown oh yeah definitely
so I'm 50 now right but I already know
50 almost for two years I'll be 50 yeah
you're not 50 yet yeah but I have my 60
year old look if I make it that long on
lockdown what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
grow my hair really long but I'm not
gonna put plugs I'm gonna have a balding
here
right but I'm gonna have a full arm
beard right I'm gonna have you know
you're right
what like a wreck I'm gonna have raccoon
eyes yeah right I'm gonna wear a poncho
or some sort of like you know how people
from Arizona wear those you know they
have that that you know that certain
color and a stack but oh yeah turquoise
turquoise see kind of coloring right I'm
gonna kind of look like a Burning Man
kind of a guy oh yeah and I want to be
like a shaman type of look what could
see you being like a wolf boy dude I'll
tell you this you go anywhere near
[ __ ] Tennessee somebody's gonna gun
you down right with all that with all
that hair on your body but dude how
crazy to think yeah in 20 years you're
gonna be able to be like oh yeah I want
this I completely covered in hair dude
here's a picture of me right there wha
what yeah what did you do there this one
I got fue hair transplant oh I see you
but something's going on with your
[ __ ] because here's the thing they
inject you and then it starts to come
down the injections come down your face
at a certain point and it all like
expands and gets expansive that's
crazy-looking I look I guess that's not
from your hair plug you got like Botox
in your face no when they do one of the
things that they put some of the what
when they do the fue when they do they
take your blood out and they get the
cells out of it the white plasma and
then they inject that just in your head
and whenever they do no wait when they
do the hair transplant they have to put
like saline or something in saline
solution and that makes its way down
your face like it over time yeah that's
too like how long does that take it
takes a couple days so you can't leave
out you can it's just risky what you do
though what you just let they use just
stayed in the house I had to go to work
I mean had to come in here and
definitely yes yeah I did a podcast
would you wear sunglasses uh no you just
full-on that face I act you look at
Benedict Cumberbatch that dude heavy on
the batch - yeah yeah it's a bad look I
look like that guy oh yeah that's the
guy from ghostbusters - bro yeah yeah
yeah wow I can't believe that even know
we had this is a clip there's a lot of
people off of getting the dress
yeah but will you give me the read some
of the comments I want to say yesterday
this is the most unnecessary hair
surgery ever it's like a girl with
double D's getting a boob job
I like surgery that's why I get it yeah
but can you give me the number because
maybe cuz I'm gonna now for sure I'm
gonna do the beard thing for sure you
should get dimples made out of hair are
not dimples but little round little hair
I want to work again bro I want to
survive in society bro I'm not gonna do
that
bro you're gonna look like little bitty
Chewbacca that [ __ ] deals cards at
night in Reno people I ain't gonna do it
I can do I know the confidence bro bro
you should get her put holy around each
eye but then you could go mate with a
raccoon imagine sneaking up on a rack
and they don't expect anything yeah
you're just pleasure and I think about
it don't let me think about it about it
I won't get any roles on nothing but
yeah oh you could easily get a role may
I ask you something
cuz you've teased it when I'm sometimes
when I'm on a sitcom or whatever you
tease me upon it do you think that's a
bad look to be on a sitcom yeah yeah
because you go no be honest with me
because you know I know that that
because I know that doing podcast and
[ __ ] is cool right I get to reach my
real fans and whatnot but every month
someone I like to dress up and do do
that but there's some times when I'm on
a sitcom I feel like it's I'm not being
creative or it's kind of selling out
there's a feeling of selling out or
something yeah I mean do you view that
or do you think it's still cool dude
because I'm gonna go to Hawaii next week
to do another magnum p.i and I love that
show love that show
God it was so good dude the old one you
liked yeah but not the new one they have
a new one anything that had a new one
yeah I'm on the new one all right you're
are you already on it I've done this is
my fourth one coming up could I see any
episodes of it yeah yeah it's online
yeah because the second season Wow yeah
yeah look at the whole Halloween as
episode that I played Yoko Ono I know
you did yeah I would love that man you
know that appear now is a Mexican dude
no way
Jay Hernandez he's a good dude man dang
that was me that was me and Jay and we
did the the Hawaii episode brah
let me see Jay Hernandez get the fridge
could click the first one see that's Jay
oh wow yeah yeah oh yeah Latino yeah so
he's Matt he's a good dude that's
Perdita week she's great too man but
yeah she looks beautiful but when I do
[ __ ] like that though does it
is that that's still a good rose am
barely you look nice
[ __ ] you were in Hawaii shooting that
yeah go to Hawaii again it's farm bro
but my point though is is that coming to
perform there saying oh you're gonna
love it
now you know oh yeah I've done it before
yeah I love it yeah at the Mac yeah man
you're gonna love it
I'm excited yeah it's gonna be great but
my point is is this is that a bad look
or no I don't think so I mean I think
there's if there's fun stuff that you do
you know I mean look everybody's their
own way you know I think some people
it's hard to like be yourself and really
like I think a lot of sitcoms and stuff
like this it's a tough place for them to
write a lot of humor because the
advertising everything gets attached and
and they're so scared about offending
people or about this and that but at the
same time I think that if there's
something that you want to do to make
yourself feel like you are being as
artistic as you can like you're saying
sometimes you want to dress up and go to
the dance sometimes you want to play in
a yard you know it's like no but
something Dubrow Pro you know my dream
is bigger than doing stand-up and
podcasts although those are my
foundations and whatnot but dude it's
you know I've been in movies before it
feels you know I I did it the O's in the
dictator and I did a scene with Ben
Kingsley mhm
and you know you're talking to a dude
like that right and it makes you feel
you learn you know and you're also like
it's exciting you know and it feels like
you know all this hard work it feels
like it sometimes it pays off because
you're around you know really good
actors and you're like I can't believe
I'm in this situation if you and you pat
yourself on the back
why what's wrong with that nothing
nothing it's good man I think is good I
just wish they were to put you on the
billboard
the last show you were in remember they
put four White's on there and then him
put you on there
what was the Billboard for that show
what was it called home improvement it's
called splitting up together letting up
together yeah yeah if Nick if you look
up that billboard on there yeah and
we'll see that they didn't put old Bob a
bear on there what and then after they
got a kid on there I keep my don't even
live that long dude you got a foot Bobby
I know but dude and I asked them there's
the first time I went to the producer go
hey can I be on the background yeah
and they go no it's for it's about a
family I could just put me in the
background yeah and they go no and they
go why and I could because the whole
reason why I wanted a sitcom is to cause
other people pain I want to be on a
billboard
so my enemies can drive by oh yeah right
and they can see Oh Bobby
well yeah yeah yeah this is a whole
point of it yeah
and they wouldn't put me on that I could
put me on the Warner brother all of us
so I could cause some people some pain
dude that happened to me with Netflix I
did a special and they put everybody
else was on a billboard that year and
mom was the only one that they didn't
put a billboard is you getting angry
yeah hurt my feelings yeah people see
here's the thing Hollywood right you
have to be conscious about it because
the thing is is that especially us bro I
will rap bro I'm gonna I'm gonna say
something right now say yeah that was at
Irvine right check this out bro and I
want to see if you could be on my side
on this okay I am on I am okay so I
Drive to Irvine improv I sold out every
show I'm not bragging it's just the fact
right that 2500 seats right there's two
restaurants adjacent to that oh yeah
Javier's Mexican joint yep I've been
there before and there's other to Palm
Martin on whatever right
so I go to Paul the restaurant first I'm
there a little early and I go hey I know
you're busy but I just need a table for
one I'm headlining next door and I
really kind of need a table I can't wait
an hour they go no okay yeah but come on
do it
I caused some
traffic to come in here at this because
I know half my fans eat here
yeah they go no I go to the improv I go
can you work something out
we don't know nobody is what they say
thinking we have a connection Javier
this is the worst one I go into Javier's
these two Mexican hosts dudes and
they're gonna have my head laying there
next door
do they have tattoos or anything no I
don't know they're clean ones you know
they're not mc5 15 or whatever right
right and so they go um no and I go dude
I just won no I could be cold I thought
The Improv called they did call we don't
give a [ __ ] I know right
so now bro I'm livid I'm [ __ ] livid
right now do I have any right to be mad
or do because the thing is is that I
played that improv 20 times in my life
I've I've helped business flow into that
area not just me but all the comics yeah
you know I mean and then so you know
maybe I maybe I'm acting like a baby
about it yeah right but do you think
that I'm in the right to be hurt and mad
about it no I don't at all man I think
you should eat over at the improv dude
because improv is good food and they can
also just bring food back to you in them
and the greenroom if you just want to
eat there I think going in there and
demanding a table for one which is
basically saying hey yeah we want a
serial killer to hang out in here for 40
minutes is one of the it just seems like
I'm not even a good idea so you're not
on my side no you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
no I am an [ __ ] but I'm not an
[ __ ] that we'd go in there [ __ ]
demanda thing no I wasn't bro stop sound
like he's the man he stopped he didn't
do anything I know but I give me his BD
his eyes his eyes are like fish he has
nerves he is fish eyes right here man up
her nervousness yeah but my point is is
this but I didn't demand anything
I was gracious about it but you stood
there and looked like you were upset
after they said whatever you know and
you kind of probably went like that with
your hands you know and you probably
can't even move your arms at high in the
air let's take another question for a
guest that came and we got some really
great ones that came in for you like
here's the guy right here about I can
hear you bro huh
sometimes that's fine hate me do this
what happens you can give
cut and come to my yard boy gang yeah
what up Theo what up Bobby it's a player
my name is Nick I'm from Utah and I just
wanted to ask you guys what your
thoughts are on a wreck tile dysfunction
you know as a young guy it's kind of
hard to go through and I just wanted to
know what your guys perspective is on it
and kind of how to deal with it gang
gang sleep nation sleep king slap king
have a good one
[ __ ] it doesn't make any sense does it
Bobby [ __ ] king I'll say this brother
gang bro gang gang but you have to wake
up got something telling you dude here's
the thing have you ever dealt with the
right tile dysfunction and I'm gonna
what do you what's really happened I
have a phenom I'm a part of a phenomenon
called porn erectile dysfunction okay
and for me dude it's like I weeded porn
out of my life really I did a nice man
for how long for the rest of my life how
long has it been out that's what I mean
since I've been sober this time so about
60 days that's awesome man yeah so now I
have to do my imagination yeah yeah but
the thing is is that um and it's a
phenomenon that's going on with
especially men Millennials because you
know you and I you're much younger than
I am but back in my day when if you
wanted to jerk off to pornography
especially as a kid you'd have to go to
the dirt lot mm-hmm there used to be a
rock a communal rock oh yeah and you
would lift it and it would be a hostile
magazine underneath there is this mildew
and titties missing wonderful beautiful
right and you would jerk off real quick
in the forest right and then you put it
back in a thing right but now you
imagine kids have access to anything
that they want right so now these kids
before they even have sex of the woman
yeah they they jerk off to [ __ ] yeah
bbw bangs an oyster you're right right
right that concept outright it's in
crazy town right so my point is is that
you have to [ __ ] completely weed it
out and I think it takes about six
months to completely reset your mind
right so my advice to you is
try not to masturbate hmm masturbate
with your imagination if you need to you
got to get it out well you don't have to
I mean you can do that nocturnal bus do
which is basically you Jack you'll out
in your sleep and a lot of people get
into that do you know I'm saying blowing
in the darkness breath you know yeah but
but like a [ __ ] trumpeter with no
electricity but you're asleep when it's
happening yeah yeah yeah so you just
wake up and there's mangu all over your
belly yeah but that's you didn't have to
you don't have to touch yourself wrong
day that's the real David Blaine right
right so do that as well yeah there's
just another way to do it if you don't
want to jerk off all it.why right but
yet it to build up that Chi and a chi up
a little yeah that's beautiful I was a
lot longest time you [ __ ] didn't
masturbate the longest time I've ever
gone probably I would say is probably
two months it's hard bro so hard to do
me so hard to do and the hard part is
for me is if I engage with someone
texting and in anything sensual or
somebody send me a dirty image yeah a
leg anything like that if it's been a
month six weeks if somebody even sent me
a leg you know you know if they even
send me like a pat man the moment the
[ __ ] ribbon in her hair
yeah I'll bust out bro one time Carlos
Mencia long time ago goes hey dude you
want to go to Honduras so he flew me to
Honduras but he didn't tell me where
basically you had to fly into Honduras
then take another little flight and hit
this dirt patch then take the canoe ride
for six hours to go to his village so
where he's from yeah that's where he's
born so then I'm in this village no
electricity no running water and I have
to be there for a month and I literally
turned him ago I'm gonna go back in the
canoe and go home because no dude so I
had to eat their food no electricity you
stayed there yeah so it's like I had a
mosquito net in a [ __ ] Shack
you don't even performing no dude I was
just there bro
and what and and I also looked at the
village there's a hundreds of female
villagers they're beautiful they're more
they're more indigenous II looking yeah
yeah yeah which they're all human beings
world yeah yeah yeah but I tell you this
right now
three weeks in I was stalking them oh
yeah because you reset your dick right
and all of a sudden like your prime you
know it's primal you know and then I
could find like parts of them that I
liked
look at that [ __ ] shoulder plane yeah
look at those kneecaps accident levees
baby yeah bro and so I was able to so I
could probably you can always reset your
[ __ ] bro it doesn't always have to be
like barely legal or the kind of old
porn I watch old J you know old J's old
Japanese no man there's a site called
old J it's like nine year old man and
eight year old women so I used to do
that
oh that's pure that's insurance simple
it's insane but good like it's pure or
simple man yeah
old J how I'm trying to think if you
went some old guy dude if I'm really old
I don't know at a certain point can
having sex I can danger you if it like
get your heart real hot you know but I
would rather die that way I think I
wouldn't I'd rather die chilling out
dude but on a [ __ ] couch watching
[ __ ] jeopardy yeah
you're on a couch and you go and then
you're done right but imagine right
having like being like who's that
playboy guy Hugh Hefner you have no
right lining up nine women and then the
third one you have a heart attack
oh yeah way to go bra playing like
Russian Hewlett right yeah yeah and also
at that is no condom you don't give a
[ __ ] bro dude any age note coming who's
even are they still making condoms
that's what I want to know for all
people for people yeah they still use it
what I haven't heard and no one's even
getting anything anymore
no people look at tell that the [ __ ]
Charlie Sheen brah oh yeah yeah you got
the hair brah but he was also basically
he was like like he was like [ __ ] he was
like having sex with like laboratories
is she like that guy yeah yeah like you
know um donkeys and the animals he go I
mean he probably got into some real dark
stuff yeah yeah that's drug induced it
drug and do is [ __ ] the iea yeah yeah
now have you ever been involved in like
drug induced homosexuality you know like
where people do enough drugs if
somebody's gay so I've done it
bro you already know you already [ __ ]
know I don't know you dude I'm thinking
if I know we're not and I don't you you
don't know that I've suck the dick
before
whoa [ __ ] no put your hand in the air
before you say that take my head forever
[ __ ] who was the guy was it a black guy
no do my my small bra yeah no here's the
thing dude um you got that baby pocket
on your face bro
here's the cool here's the guy right now
finish it though yeah all right go ahead
no no you go let me finish what the dick
thing please do okay so back when I told
you like I couldn't get laid or whatever
as a kid right so when I was a child
right I would be at a party and some
dude would just go
it was actually one or two dudes they
would go suck my dick and they just
grabbed my hair and I'd suck their dick
anyway let's go to the tape Jesus man
who calls it a party Asian guy huh
hey Theo hey Bobby love you guys both
just good question for you for the both
of you guys if you guys turn gay for a
day who would you hit up that's hit
hanggang I'm not gay but I like gay
people peace out dude ah Marty Tom Hardy
yeah I'm Rob Marty is tag X bro not Tom
Arnold imagine sucking him off I'm not
sucking anybody dude I might bang the
guy I'm not blowing some dude brothers
the gayest thing ever oh let me ask you
something what would it take for you to
blow somebody I wouldn't do it for okay
so let me ask you this then okay right
Jesus came down oh Christ
okay not messing blowing cry I'm not
gonna say that okay no Jew glow Christ
it would you blow Christ nope okay good
even if you're gonna be an attorney in
hell dude I'm not I'm not blowing
anybody so all right he's the Lord but
fine um but what if Jesus said a real
Jesus wouldn't want it it would be a
fake Jesus then right but if Jesus or
something out Jesus but some alien then
is that better for you okay like Sandra
Bernhard you mean yeah yeah sounder
Bernhardt came down right that bad at me
right and goes I will destroy all
mankind if you don't blow Eric Griffin
no man I just couldn't I don't want my
mouth to be open by some guy's wiener
that's what I that's the part I always
the prying factor it's intrusive yeah I
just don't I don't think I'd like the
texture of it the textures [ __ ] it's
like a finger Brian uh yeah but it's
somebody else's finger that's near
they're freaking nuts right it was a
mankind if mankind was all gonna die I
would suck whoever whoever I'd suck the
guy who is most qualified to help us
save the universe
well in America blow us up scared about
what's going on
you know yeah but I like your attitude
you've never done anything gay in your
life uh
I've never done anything gay man they
had a time well I think it dude was
trying to get me to be gay one time and
I had to go to the airport and and we've
been doing cocaine and so I'm glad to go
to the airport man because I that's the
thing at a certain point there can be
drug induced homosexuality yeah were you
doing of drugs and next thing you know
man you get you know people can coerce
you into things can I tell you a funny
story I was uh I was living in Silver
Lake bro and you knew Mike Young is yeah
yeah so Mike Young was like 3:00 in the
morning calls me to goes dude I'm drunk
brah that's what he says oh yeah go I
think I'm hanging up and he goes no dude
I don't know where's my car
oh yeah that's a gay pick up my cart at
your house right meanwhile you need to
have a house yeah and then the guys and
he goes uh come pick me out dude I lost
before over all that hair right so I go
no he's crying oh man right everybody
you almost bang is crying in this right
no so I pick him up and I go all right
dude what's up he said where's your car
because I remember it's up here so he we
drop up in the hills and we pull up to
this mansion and it's Tobey Maguire's
house oh yeah right it goes hey man I
called Leo Leo and Mark Wahlberg and
Toby were Jacuzzi
right and I go yeah and he goes they
said you could come too and I go no just
in case hmm
now I'm not acute at Dave they're
probably needy [ __ ] oh that's them
they're not gay at all but even if there
was a 1% chance that I mean this Jacuzzi
and then spider-man's dick is in my face
I would have to suck it because I want
to make it in the business
dang so I didn't I put myself out of the
situation
oh you think you're honestly party was
afraid to go I think it was I think also
um that was part of it and also I don't
want to say the wrong thing it's late
it's 4:00 in the morning now
like I don't want to fight you're not
gonna do anything good yeah there's
nothing good that's gonna happen from it
I'm not gonna get in a movie no you're
right so I you're in a movie it's gonna
be a short movie dude assist me on
somebody's phone and it's just gonna be
you huh
yeah just holster in that spider wean
yeah
I'll probably some idiot leo off made me
would you maybe he's [ __ ] a star bra
I love once I put time in Hollywood
here's a guy right now and there's a
question that's gonna be much better
than this conversation let's take it to
it
feel it's okay Bobby hey Bobby I would
like to if I make and I would love to
ask you a question a lot of times my
brain is telling me one thing my heart's
telling me another thing a mother a lot
of times I'm not sure which way to go
so I wanted to ask you how do you send
to yourself when you feel overwhelmed or
lost or anxious thank you thank you very
much
god bless you both Wow it's nice guy
method yeah baby holy definitely made
that in the late night hour that's crazy
eyes yeah he's like three or four
grandfather clocks in his room so yeah
if that's a serious quiet is a serious
question you know what I've been doing
dude is uh meditating yeah and I every
night I am and in the mornings I spent
20 minutes and I focus on my breathing
I'm in a room you know I live in a
mansion so you know you know I mean one
of my rooms and I concentrate on my
breathing and I what I do is I breathe
in five seconds you know breathe out
five seconds breathe in five seconds and
I know that thoughts enter my brain you
know I mean like how the [ __ ] did
conjunct in another movie or whatever
hear me or like you know if [ __ ]
crystally you know I mean but the I
chose I let those pass like clouds hmm
or I pop them like a bubble like me if
that's I got four thoughts above I pop
it right and I focus my attention on my
breathing that's how I do it and once I
do that I get locked into nothingness
not nothingness but like it's just black
yeah right and once I get in that state
I mean a groove it really dictates how I
feel about my life and how that my gay
goes and it also makes me sleep so much
[ __ ] better dude yeah I
instantaneously sleep rather than toss
and turn for an hour
hmm right you know what dude all my
problems come from here yeah and they're
mostly your brain my Mei my mind my
brain yeah and it's also most of my
problems are not real yeah they're
perceived I imagine things that don't
exist how what people are saying why
didn't I get that none of it [ __ ]
matters man right so it's like that's
what meditation does it calms the part
of the thing that's mostly my problem
which is this yeah
so that's what I've been trying to do as
of late you know and what practice are
you doing like is there a certain way
you're practicing is hurting my time
like what are you doing I try to do
about 20 minutes bro Wow 20 minutes a
good time you know I mean maybe a little
longer I don't have a clock I just eats
generally about 20-25 minutes that I
last sometimes 30 you know right
sometimes shorter it depends but like it
I really do try to do it because it's
like you know that relapse I had in
August dude and I was gonna kill myself
Dane you said dang a little too quick
sorry hell in a second dang man
yeah thanks that felt more organic but
yeah I you know when my dad died I
relapsed and then you know after 17
years you know that's a long time yeah
and then I couldn't eat sleep and I had
thoughts of suicide and were you using
weed and liquor just weed do you have
any liquor no do you wish you'd had a
beer I couldn't do it because the thing
is is that I had gotten this CBS game
show job and I did do eight episodes I
knew I was gonna drink after that and do
opiates and do all my fun Thon's
yeah loose energetics yeah but what
ended up happening was I was losing so
much weight and I wasn't sleeping and I
started getting psychotic I started
losing my mind yeah you don't wanna yeah
so then I went to a hospital I went to a
place in Arizona for a couple of weeks
and I found out what the problem was and
the problem was the trauma that my dad
caused me as a kid Wow and so I had a
deal I didn't EMDR a lot of therapy and
I've addressed a lot of those issues and
I took the weight out of those things
and now I feel freer I think also this
time because you know in the last seven
years of this
17 years I was sober I didn't good you
know I rarely went to meetings Oh Riley
yeah so now what I'm doing is it's the
first thing it's the most important
thing going to meetings is going to my
therapist once a week and going to
meetings and those are things that are
gonna be ritualistic and things that I
am never gonna like you know ignore or
not do they're important
yeah more important than my podcast my
family everything because it's my life
they're puttin things first yet I'd
rather be free and happy then make it or
get money or that it's it's [ __ ] all
of the others is [ __ ] you know bro it
doesn't make you happy oh yeah I agree
move on oh you were gonna say about
seeing Richard Pryor bring up a question
yeah oh yeah yeah you work with Richard
Pryor well I don't working with him is
not but you know when I was a doorman
it's um when I moved to Hollywood you
know he was sick but he would still do
spots and he would come with his
wheelchair and we would both like Freddy
Soto Bob Oh Shaq we would have to lift
him up on stage put him and then like he
would have boogers on his nose and we
would wipe them like from coke no cuz he
was sick oh he's that sick yeah yeah
yeah and because he couldn't do it
himself you know I mean and we put the
mic there and it was a blessing to watch
that man cuz he was still super funny
even in that state he has another dude
that used to come in is Carlin well I
was working the back door once the first
time George Carlin ever went there and I
was working the back door and he came up
to me I was so scared because I'm a
[ __ ] huge fan and he who came up to
me and he goes what's your name and I go
Bobby Lee
nice to meet you I'm George he did a
show he did it every year for three
years in a row and every year I'd orde
every year I'd orde there he would walk
along by me and go mr. Lee he remembered
and those kind of guys taught me class
that's gone away from from stand-up
comedy is
class you knew who has it Sebastian yeah
yeah I mean but a lot of these younger
kids and I want to name names right now
I'm not going to there's a somebody that
made it that I helped it was interests
instrumental in that person making it a
woman a man a man or a woman or yeah
yeah no class hmm
they bit little me at each every chance
I get and so it's like for me I'm still
gonna have you know for me I'm Korean
and I Joe Rogan's you know Joe goes to
me how come you're so distant in front
of me because I respect you and when you
come to the Comedy Store you have a
thousand comics or surround you right
I get why but I'm gonna step back
because I don't want to be intrusive
because I respect you and you're the
you're them one of the kings of the game
right and he respected that yeah it's
class right so I learned from the all
those old Fox man yeah right so that's
that do you feel like you've I mean
there's you've had issues at the Comedy
Store recently right you've mentioned
this ones on your podcast I've had
issues yeah yeah what's going on what do
you mean what's going on you don't want
to be at the Comedy Store I don't want
to be the Comedy Store because um the
Comedy Store used to be a place where if
you put your time in you got treated
right like the man right but now it's
Fame that dictates it and whoever is hot
and there's people that are get spots
every single night they don't have to
necessarily even call in mm-hmm
right that that's now the name of the
game right so dudes that have been there
like you know like me I get spots right
but I don't get every single night and
I'll get some some of these hat fools
get to shows yeah a night right and so
it's been a place it's also a place not
to grow it's because you see you're
there it's sold out you're you're
performing with heavy weights right how
the [ __ ] do you try new [ __ ] yeah
I can't it's hard because I can't I have
to survive because when you're in the
audience now has I in this last year
I've seen Francis Ford Coppola in the
audience I've seen Quentin Tarantino in
the audience I've seen the biggest
people in the game just sitting on is
what I'm gonna do my first Tenten in
mind for ten minute new [ __ ] yeah no I'm
gonna kill it
so that I can maybe get in you know I
mean in your life yeah so you can play a
nunchuck and Kill Bill three let's go to
a question right here in Moore Bobby
what up the oh I got a question for
Bobby fourth-grade my best friend was
Korean his parents his grandma I living
I'm straight from Korea mmm barely spoke
any English his grandmother's speak any
English damn and every time I came over
to sleepover all they would do is order
Papa John's and then for breakfast in
the morning she would microwave the Papa
John's like not even throw it in the
oven microwave pieces especially Papa
John's crazy so my question is do you
guys microwave your pizzas after or you
throw that [ __ ] in the oven or at a
toaster oven or is that just a Korean
thing all right gang gang gang bruh
what's up with the Marines bruh
drop that k knowledge on your boy cuz we
want to know you [ __ ] brother
y'all over there slipping and sliding
not taking the shortcuts brought you
guys a chef's shortcut so what we yeah
yeah really those are the first of all
number one those are ghetto Koreans okay
okay GK is they call them yeah we there
was a GK's for sure okay okay number two
Koreans came especially my family came
from poverty hmm my parents my mother um
when she was 8 years old when she walked
her little sister's school a military
truck military truck ran my on over and
those n trailed over the street so
there's no ambulance so um my uncle's
had to pick up my dead aunt
put him in rice bags so this is this is
the light this is the
yeah so this is this is the experience
that they come from that's why they
microwave their [ __ ] Papa John's who
gives a [ __ ]
number two who gives a [ __ ] right and
number two let me say this friend
alright is is that you know what my mom
you said that's evil I'll tell you even
something worse if you didn't finish
your cereal it right you have frosted
flakes you put the milk in right
you ate the cereal but you're full hmm
right you leave it mm-hmm you go to
school the next morning guess what's
back in the box the soggy the soggy
[ __ ] cereal flakes and you had to eat
it or you get beep amen brother [ __ ] you
and the Papa Papa a man is you have
another question no no wow how long does
this go for Matt's it man I think we've
done enough - I thought that question
was gonna make it more lighthearted well
no I like it when it goes in and out how
long did we do our 45 yeah that's a lot
man that was awesome
Bobby Lee I love you man I love you well
you know I love you I wish you would do
a show together sometime man bro not
only that I don't want to be real
there's a lot of heads bro sometimes
some of these fools they get successful
mm-hmm and I get it why I think
sometimes I'll be honest you know but
all the good [ __ ] that's happened to you
bro you you are so resilient and your
voice is so original I am so [ __ ]
proud of you dude you're so funny dude
you're so funny you're so intrinsically
funny and I just my hats off to your
brother I love you bro I love you too
man I appreciate that yeah man you're a
good guy Bobby Lee ladies and gentlemen
and we'll see in the future man check
out Bobby's new podcast ginger ginger
what is it
bad friends with Andrew Santino
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]